the yg
song getting you know a song came out in
2013
right um and i i
i liked the song as like it was i mean
it's a classic album in my opinion
i wasn't really a fan of
first of all the song's been out for as
long as it's been out so anybody who's
heard it
has heard it and i thought that the
whole outcry of it
if anything brought more people to
listen to the song um
but what were your thoughts on that song
kind of
getting canceled i guess
i mean i i think i know
what he say on it he said he said um
something find an asian neighborhood
and go in their house because they don't
keep cash and [ __ ] like that right
pretty much exactly what he said that's
basically what he said basically what he
said
okay
bruh i mean that's the truth
you know what i'm saying that's the
[ __ ] truth asian people
well you know what i'm saying since i
was a kid that's uh
asian people keep cash in the house they
don't like to go to the bank
you know what i mean and and they wear
they wear good jewelry you know what i'm
saying so if i'm a robber
i'm gonna go to the easy vic you know
what i'm saying i'm gonna go where i
know there's money why the [ __ ] i'm
gonna go here you know money here
oh they got money they coming from the
stores whatever boom
boom all right you know what i'm saying
that if i'm a robber it's not a race
thing
you're forced it's not i'm not racist
doing it it's a crime of opportunity
and you make that available you make
that available then that that's
something that
that's a situation that you made
available you understand i'm saying so
once people
start understanding what you're doing
then it's up to us
to change it now i don't think i think
it was irresponsible
on his behalf you feel me but you know i
don't think he was talking
i was he was thinking about
responsibility when he made that song
i definitely think it was irresponsible
but it was his truth it's his truth
i don't think my thing was when i
started hearing people call it
quote-unquote racist
and i'm like man i know yg like why
she's not a racist dude right
i don't think he was i don't think that
was a racist thing
i think that was an opportunistic
opportunistic thing like that's that's
that's what
the people in their communities they
know like all right we gonna rob
[ __ ] we we know that they keep cash so
we gonna go over there he just said
what everybody in those communities
think you know what i'm saying and if
anything that should be
game for us to be like i we gotta switch
our [ __ ] the [ __ ] up
cause they understand what the [ __ ] we
doing you know what i'm saying and
and i i mean i don't think that i don't
really have
i don't think that you know um them i
don't really have a
a take on them pulling the song or
keeping the song up right
what i feel like is he just sheds some
light
on what the [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying or what the [ __ ]
is reality you know what i mean but he
definitely was was
he definitely like you know he
definitely was irresponsible in that
matter i don't think
you know now that he knows certain [ __ ]
i don't think he would say the same
thing
i don't think so i don't know right but
you know i don't think so you feel me
but um but yeah it's 2020 right right
but i don't think that
taking down that song does anything what
the [ __ ] does that do yeah that's my
thing is like
what does that do except for make people
be like wait what's the song talking
about let me go find it cause you're
gonna be able to find it on youtube and
find it somewhere
right like i think our people are
worried about the wrong [ __ ]
you worry about a [ __ ] song bro i
would also venture to say that whoever
created that outrage might not have been
and it sounds like some real like caring
ass white girls woke twitter [ __ ] no but
i heard
asian people talking about it i'm saying
the asian people were outraged at it you
know what i'm saying
and but were they outraged like when it
came out
no because they didn't know about it you
know and the thing is is the song was
bigger than ever the first few months it
came out because that album was huge for
you but but here's the thing they
probably asian people probably knew
about it but we didn't say anything
about it
you know what i'm saying so now because
of all of this speaking up
okay we're talking about this right all
right so we will talk about this and
talk about this
talk about [ __ ] that [ __ ] ain't
talking about before you know i'm saying
it wasn't an issue before you know what
i'm saying but it's an issue now but
what i'm
all i'm saying is our people needs to
worry about
our [ __ ] like let's worry about what the
[ __ ] we doing wrong here you know what
i'm saying
if we if we know that our parents and
our grandparents
don't y'all don't carry cash we're gonna
have to kind of shift them
to i listen you keeping cash is gonna
make this is gonna make people wanna
come rob you and [ __ ] like that you know
what i'm saying
so we gonna have to shift we're gonna
have to we don't have to talk to our
elders
and we're gonna have to do some changing
you know what i mean you know
so i mean that's what it is people are
hurting out here
people there's a lot of people that
ain't getting money out here there's a
lot of people that's
that's that's just homeless jobs
are very desperate in the world right
now so yes yes um
crimes against like asian attacks is up
but like i said before
crimes are everybody every every crime
is up
every crime is up you feel me so knowing
that
my brothers and sisters it's time for us
to [ __ ] change a couple things
out here we can't be doing the same [ __ ]
we was doing
two years ago because it's not the same
place you feel me
and if we keep on doing the same [ __ ]
without no change then we gonna [ __ ]
around
we gonna catch a bad one